welcome to this episode of uxd where we
will talk more about leading UX and how
to measure changes in user behavior to
determine whether your design decisions
were good or bad
I'm your host Nazmul Idris a developer
advocate passionate about design and
mobile and have a very special guest
with me on the show today hi I'm Laura
Klein I'm a user experience designer who
loves data thanks for inviting me
you must welcome and thank you for being
here so lean UX is a way to apply the
methods of learning as quickly as
possible and reducing the cycle time
through what's called the build measure
and learn loop to the process of user
experience design now practicing lean UX
means that you're always validating with
users that you're designing something
that people actually use it's about
designing products that are both usable
and useful Laura wrote a really good
book about this called UX for lean
startups in this episode we're going to
talk about qualitative and quantitative
research what they are how to use them
and most importantly why to use them so
Laura why do developers and designers
need to know different types of research
what's that got to do with building
products it's an excellent question so
research both qualitative and
quantitative is the key to building
great products without measuring the
results of our work
through things like analytics a be
testing qualitative research and a host
of other methods we really can't
understand the impact that our changes
are having on end-users this means that
we can do things like make good product
choices or you know learn from any
mistakes we might make that make sense
so these are just different ways of
measuring results so what is qualitative
research exactly qualitative research is
about observing and listening to people
so it includes things like usability
testing customer development interviews
and in context studies where you know
you might observe somebody using a
product in their natural environment
there are tons of types of qualitative
research but you can tell a research is
qualitative if it involves talking to
people or observing real human behavior
I see that make sense so now these tests
didn't sound like they're statistically
significant credit that's right they're
not oh so why do you do them what are
they good for so they're great for
things
understanding the problem that you're
gonna solve for a user or learning the
context that your product is going to be
used in they're also great for building
empathy and for really understanding the
person that you're building the product
for that makes sense so what about
quantitative research how is that
different than qualitative so
qualitative research is often the
preferred method of engineers oh it
includes things like analytics a be
testing funnel metrics it's always
statistically significant and it never
really involves talking to humans code
might be why it's so beloved of
Engineers but quantitative research as
the name implies is all about the data
that makes sense so I get to pick
whichever one I like right no sadly you
do not see quality quantity two really
different things about both your user
and your product as a general rule
quantitative research tells you exactly
what is happening with your product
while qualitative research tells you why
it's happening so quant is what got it
qual is why if you use both of these
together you get an enormous amount of
information about both your product and
your users and you can come up with some
great ideas about how to make it better
but I make sense that's really cool so
can you give me an example how they work
together
yeah so let's imagine that you have a
product and you're actually charging
people to use it what I know crazy but I
thought you might like it so at some
point you need to actually put the
people through a checkout flow of some
sort
ah so you mean getting their payment
information shipping and billing address
and so on exactly ah so you can
visualize your checkout flow as a funnel
let's imagine that this particular flow
requires all sorts of things that it it
requires people to create an account
select the plan they want enter their
credit card in the dress information
confirm the purchase and then the final
screen is the thank you screen so you
want to measure not just how many people
make it all the way through to the thank
you screen you also want to measure the
drop off at each step of the funnel why
is that well it gives you more detailed
information about where people are
getting stuck see picture that funnel
100% of the people who want to buy your
product or think they want to buy your
product start at the first step and then
let's say you lose 20% there then maybe
you lose 10% at the next step and
and 50% of the remaining people drop us
the next step ouch
and then maybe a third on the last step
and that means that only a small
percentage of the people who started at
the top are actually getting to the
bottom of the funnel
Thanks so if you start with a hundred
people then you've got a 80 and then 72
and then 36 and then 24 Wow
and suddenly only 24 people are actually
making it through to the end and paying
you for your product but the nice thing
about knowing how many people you lose
in each step is that you could use that
information to decide which step to make
changes to in order to best increase the
number of people who make it all the way
to the end
oh I see so you might want to make some
changes in this case to step three where
you're losing 50% of the people that's
right that's clearly a friction point
but of course at this point we just know
that people are dropping off there we
don't know why yet can we just guess hmm
well we could but our guess this would
be a lot better if we did some
observational user research to
understand whether there's a specific
problem that people are having on that
step so for example maybe there's
something really confusing or maybe
there's some information that people
don't have available to them on that
step right or maybe the page just loads
really slowly for some people by
observing five or six people going
through that whole checkout flow you can
start to make some much better guesses
about what you'd want to fix on that
step three that makes sense so now let's
say we know what the problem is what do
we do then well then you fix it of
course if it involves big changes to
that step work to the rest of the flow
you might want to do some qualitative
usability research while you're
designing it common that can help make
sure that your next version of the
checkout flow doesn't introduce new
usability problems so when you're pretty
sure you've got a good change to the
product you build it in you ship it that
makes sense but that's not the end of
course you still need to release the fix
in an a/b test oh yeah
so a be testing is another form of
quantitative research this means that we
can validate that we've really fixed the
problem that we had and we have an
introduced nuance
I see so this way we've identified what
the problem is with quantitative
research and then we've got an idea of
why the problems happening with
qualitative but then we actually then
use qualitative research to help design
the change and then confirm that we
fixed it with quantitative again exactly
wow that's cool that makes sense so I'm
gonna play a devil's advocate now so
I've heard that it's not worth it to do
qualitative research because users
really don't know what they want so
asking them is useless is that true well
I've heard that too and it's a
fundamental misunderstanding of how to
do good qualitative user research ah so
let's let's be totally clear if you're
just asking people what you should build
and then going in building it you're
probably not gonna make a very good
product that's 100% true but to be fair
you're not actually doing good
qualitative research you're just
outsourcing your entire product
development process to your users and
you know what they're probably not great
at designing fantastic products truth
that's your job yes you're supposed to
be designing the product so if you learn
good qualitative user research skills
you're gonna be able to learn a huge
amount from your users without ever once
asking that question so what do you
think this product should do that makes
sense
so now what about the argument that you
cannot make big design changes with a/b
testing and quantitative research I've
heard that oh I mean I've heard a lot of
designers say that yeah a lot of them do
you say that and again it's a complete
misunderstanding this time of
quantitative research see remember
analytics a be testing funnel metrics
those are just tools are there they're
hammers you can test anything you want
using these tools the fact that you're
doing a/b testing doesn't dictate what
you can test oh I mean you could test
you know button colors or 42 shades of
blue or whatever you want all sorts of
little optimizations like that right but
you can also test entirely different
flows against one another
you can test how users behave when they
have a new feature against how they
behave when they don't have the new
feature a B testing isn't just for
optimization
it's a marvelous tool for understanding
the real impact that your design changes
are having on the end user that makes
sense so it sounds like using
quantitative and qualitative together is
more powerful than just
using each one by itself that's exactly
right that makes sense
so that's all we have time for today if
you'd like to learn more about
qualitative and quantitative research
methods please check out Laura's book UX
for lean startups it's amazing it is a
lot of tips and tactics for doing the
right kind of research at the right time
Laura thanks again for joining us here
oh thanks so much for having me it was
my pleasure
go build something awesome and finally
if you haven't already please join our
UX community on Google+ thanks again for
watching and good bye